welcome back to cbs morning's today
marks 25 years since princess diana was
tragically killed in a car crash in
paris well this morning people are
gathered outside the former home in
london kensington palace to pay their
respects as they do every year they are
honoring the memory of the people's
princess holly williams looks back at
diana's enduring legacy and spoke with
one of the last people to talk with her
before the accident
she was a princess
a rebel
and a mother
[Music]
who lived her short life in the glare of
the cameras
could i ask you to respect my children's
space
until suddenly her light went out diana
princess of wales is dead after a car
crash in paris they were apparently
being pursued by paparazzi
on two motorcycles
the british people famous for their
stiff upper lip were overcome in their
heartbreak
for themselves
and for diana's two young sons
do you miss her i miss her hugely i miss
i miss her laughter and i just miss that
sort of spontaneous thing when she call
and say come to lunch or do you want to
see a movie
richard kaye is a journalist who struck
up an unlikely friendship with diana and
told us he spoke to the princess the
night she died i was one of the last
four or five people that she called
what did you talk about
it dealt a lot with um the publicity
that had sort of surrounded those last
uh days and weeks of her life and she
she knows she talked about how fed up
she was now i had heard this before but
this time i felt she really meant it she
talked about leaving the country she
talked about going to america settling
there
on paper she was a perfect fit for the
royal family i'm not going to say
anything
aristocratic beautiful and demure and i
suppose in love
but even before her so-called fairytale
wedding she'd become something unique a
royal who was also a megawatt celebrity
as things turned frosty with prince
charles she became a rule breaker
championing causes like hiv patients and
landmines you just know and giving this
bombshell interview about her troubled
marriage well there were three of us
in this marriage so it was a bit crowded
we now know the journalist lied to get
the interview her relationship with the
media was always complicated her legacy
of course is mainly uh
rests in the shape of her sons what
would she make of the fact that they had
this falling out i think that uh were
she's still with us
there would have been no split between
harry and william
if she was still alive today what would
she be doing ah well i mean she'd be
61.
she'd obviously be a very proud granny
grandmother she might have remarried she
might even have had a second family she
wanted
desperately wanted to have a daughter or
two
in recent years she's been portrayed in
films like spencer
and the tv series the crown but there
was only one diana
and even the glittering younger
generation of royals can't recapture her
magic a strange cocktail of glamour and
vulnerability
this is kensington palace diana's former
home and you can see the tributes that
people have laid out in her honor
arguably one of the biggest impacts she
had on this country was to make the
royal family a little bit more relaxed a
little more down to earth perhaps even a
bit more human
nate
holly williams at kensington palace
thank you the magic and her story yeah
when you think about too all that she
had to deal with with the paparazzi
especially that night yeah that she was
killed and members of the royal family
at her funeral fact blamed the paparazzi
there was a big gallup poll of the
british public uh more than 40 percent
thought the photo the photographers were
extremely to blame for what happened you
know she had she embodied royalty but i
think her her best quality was her
relatability that's what the world loves
and her love for her sons yeah yeah no
doubt about it i